antoine l'assemblée générale de l'onu a
donc rejeté deux propositions de
résolution visant à soutenir la lutte
contre le communisme neuf l'un des deux
textes étaient donc proposé par la
russie en quoi consiste exactement cette
résolution et le texte était en fait une
version modifiée du projet de résolution
russe déjà rejetée par les etats-unis
l'union européenne le royaume uni
l'ukraine et la géorgie le 3 avril
dernier il appelait alors la levée des
sanctions internationales en particulier
contre les pays les qui ont le plus de
mal à lutter contre contre le sco vide
le document a donc été reformulée
réclamé cette fin un engagement des
états membres de l'onu à faire face aux
défis sanitaires actuelles entre voisins
c'est à dire en s'abstenant la pause et
des mesures protectionnistes et
discriminatoire en contradiction des
règles de l'omc sans surprise le projet
russe a de nouveau été bloquée d'après
une source diplomatique par les
etats-unis et l'union européenne mais
aussi comme vous l'avez dit par israël
et la corée du sud 2 allié proche de
washington
la mission russe à l'onu a qualifié ce
nouvel échec de je cite démonstration
claire que les appels à la solidarité au
bénéfice des pays aux ressources
limitées ne sont rien de plus qu'une
manoeuvre de propagande des diplomates
russes regrette que ceux qui ont rejeté
le texte n'ont pas entendu donc pas
prises en compte l'appel du secrétaire
général de l'onu qui a écrit début mars
dans une lettre au g20
c'est le moment de la solidarité et non
de l'exclusion